it's official Bill and Ted they're back
by home Alex winter and I'm Kira Nerys
and together we are wild stallions it
looks like we might actually hopefully
make a movie this summer villain 3 face
the music
yes yes way our favorite time-traveling
dudes broke the excellent news yesterday
strange things are afoot and the
circle-k so here's what we know the
movie arrives over 30 years after the
original and goes into production in New
Orleans this summer with an August 2020
release date party on dudes it's being
written by the same guys who wrote the
first two so expect plenty of bodacious
humor it has billing destiny there now
middle-aged dads who must save the world
with their music we can also tell you
there will be some cameos by a few music
legends you are going to have the most
excellent adventure through history we
were with the guys on the set of their
second adventure back then the idea of a
third movie was totally bogus to them so
would change their minds it is all
because of you guys and sorry or your
huge debt of gratitude we wanted to say
thank you thank you and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]